Republican Senator Rand Paul supported
owl sting FBI director Comey he was the
only no vote during commis 2013
confirmation Senator Paul joins us from
Capitol good morning senator good
morning thanks for having me it is quite
unusual to fire an FBI director if not
unprecedented for the reasons should
president has Trump had a replacement in
mind when he did it you know I don't
know that but I would say Bill Clinton
would be the president I guess that was
the last president who fired an FBI
director after an ethics investigation
is it okay with you that Attorney
General Jeff Sessions who would recuse
himself from the investigation was
pretty much involved in the decision to
let James Comey go does that square with
you you know I think we've probably
never had someone fired where both sides
actually really agreed with the firing
more than you would imagine
almost every prominent Democrat in the
country has called for a commis after
most Democrats felt like he insinuated
Hillary Clinton's guilt and then did not
indict her most Republicans felt like
well you know with all the evidence of
her guilt and with him saying so much in
the press conference about what she did
wrong why didn't the indict her so I
don't think you've ever had an FBI
director where both sides actually were
very unhappy with him
Harry Reid called for his ouster that's
not the question is not Schumer said
senator Johnson for interrupting you but
Russia more Chuck Schumer also said he
had lost confidence in him so I think it
is the question both sides really had
lost confidence in him and I think
that's why he's gone no the question is
is it okay with you two have Attorney
General Jeff Sessions be involved in
this decision when he had recused
himself from the investigation well the
hierarchy is that the FBI director works
for the Department of Justice and works
for the Attorney General and works for
the assistant attorney general and so I
think that you would go through a normal
process to review someone's work record
before getting rid of them and I think
they summarily dismissed Comey earlier
on without going through that process
you know all the left-wing media would
have been up in arms with that too but I
think it is funny though that nobody's
really emphasizing the hypocrisy of
Democrats who were all for his ouster
and have clamored I mean moveon.org has
got a huge petition to get rid of him
all right the left is wanted to get
rid of him for six months we finally do
with the left once and now that can only
complain and make up stories about how
it means oh the end of the Republic but
I think it's far from that
no senator it's clear the people on both
sides wanted him to go the question has
always been about the timing of it
that's all senator let me ask you no but
but but the explanation I think it's a
very reasonable when the explanation is
they needed to go through a work review
of his prod and have someone evaluate it
from his bosses point of view and his
bosses were delayed by Democrats for
months we had the slowest approval of a
cabinet really in the history of our
country because of partisan differences
so sessions was delayed and then so was
his assistant when they finally got in
place they did a review and I absolutely
believed that from the election there's
been discussion of letting Comey go
because nobody's been happy with him
I've also been unhappy with him because
of his brock concerns about privacy but
also with concerns about investigating
the Orlando killing I think the FBI
dropped the ball there were many warning
signs that could have led to a stopping
the Orlando shooting and I think the FBI
would never admit that they made any
mistakes in that and I think we're
unwilling to really improve the process
important an important point I'm senator
I know you're on the Senate Foreign
Relations Committee I want to get your
take on what occurred in the Oval Office
yesterday President Vladimir Putin asked
a president Trump to invite the Foreign
Minister and the Ambassador into the
Oval Office these only pictures were
released came from the Russian media
what's your take
I'm not sure what the point is are what
your question is
what do you think of inviting the
Russian Foreign Minister in the
Ambassador into the Oval Office you know
I'm a big proponent of diplomacy as
opposed to war and I think anytime we
can have relations even with our
adversaries it's a good idea and I think
the biggest mistake we have and really
the the worst part of Washington is you
know I was at a meeting yesterday with a
general McMaster in the National
Security Council and every Republican
every Democrat wants to increase troops
from Afghanistan there's very few voices
here who don't want more war so when
Trump does something that shows that he
is entertaining diplomacy as opposed to
that Wars always answer we should stand
up and cheer because there's too many
Republicans and too many Democrats up
here who want
nothing more than perpetual war and you
think Russia can be our friend in
Afghanistan no I think throughout the
world a realistic approach is that
Russia is our adversary and on many
fronts we will confront them but on
others we will understand that they're
not necessarily going away they've been
in Syria for 50 years they have a naval
base there they're not going away the
ultimate answer in Syria will include
Russia whether we like it or not that's
the realistic point of view and I think
Trump's administration is leaning more
towards realism that may be the new
conservatism of George W Bush so I'm
very hopeful all right senator Paul
always good to have you here thank you
so much for your time